the centers for disease control and
prevention is urging teens to get
vaccinated in a new report issued friday
the agency says the number of
adolescents hospitalized with the virus
rose last month and nearly one-third of
them required intensive care
it comes as just more than half of all
adults in the u.s
have received at least one dose of the
vaccine with
41 percent of the country now fully
vaccinated
all this says the u.s now has the lowest
number of new infections
since march of last year michael george
is here with the latest michael good
morning
elaine good morning in the push to get
more people vaccinated the focus on kids
is taking on greater urgency as many are
returning to school and they're
socializing more
and new evidence this week shows just
how vulnerable they are
the u.s just entered its second month
vaccinating adolescents
but almost a quarter of new covit 19
cases
are in children and teens i strongly
encourage parents to get their teens
vaccinated
as i did mine kovid hit kids
hard a third hospitalized in the first
three months of the year
went to intensive care nearly 5 percent
were on respirators a new cdc study
found
the agency's director said yesterday
she's deeply concerned by the number of
hospitalized adolescents
that's one reason health officials are
combining kid-friendly celebrations with
vaccination events
this one is in new york city
[Music]
such events are also about getting
accurate information to combat
misinformation
that's posing a threat in vaccine
hesitant places like alabama
where dr karen landers is a health
officer we are concerned that even if we
get through this summer with relatively
low rates that we
could see an increase in the fall
alabama along with mississippi and
louisiana
have the lowest percentages of adults
who have received at least one dose
a stark comparison to vermont hawaii and
massachusetts with the highest
vaccination rates
i encourage everyone to get vaccinated
because of the freedoms this vaccine has
provided for me
my family and my community sally sliger
joined the get vaccination campaign
after winning colorado's 1 million
dollar vaccine lottery drawing
incentives are far and wide we will
start with number 18.
even in california where 38 million
doses have been delivered the most of
any state california's governor gavin
newsom is giving unvaccinated people the
chance to win a million
and new york just announced starting
monday children and staff at schools and
summer camps
will not be required to wear masks even
if they haven't been vaccinated
health officials cite the state's lowest
in the country coveted rate
jeff michael thank you in